[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
uno de los asuntos que más polémica está
desatando en francia en este final de
año la violencia policial una
problemática que desde luego es
extendible a otros países para ello me
acompañan ya en este estudio nuestros
invitados rafael plus periodista
político en el diario la opinión
bienvenido rafael hola buenas gracias
por la invitación
miguel martínez corresponsal de tv
azteca bienvenido miguel gracias y en
dúplex federico tarragoní sociólogo
especializado en movimientos o populares
de la universidad parís diderot señor
tarragoní buenos días
buenos días la violencia policial en
francia hoy nuestro asunto en primera
plana
bueno pues francia vive un contexto
político delicado por las crecientes
denuncias de violencia policial y
racismo en las fuerzas del orden una
tensión quedó aumentando tras varios
episodios como la brutal paliza un
productor de música negro el pasado 21
de noviembre o las sucesivas
manifestaciones contra una ley impulsada
por el gobierno que pretendía restringir
filmar a las fuerzas del orden en este
contexto el presidente manuel macrón ha
reconocido que existen controles
policiales discriminatorios en función
del color de piel y ha convocado para
enero una gran cumbre entre
representantes policiales ciudadanos y
cargos públicos para reformar la policía
vamos a repasar algunas portadas que nos
dejan los últimos capítulos de esta
extensa situación en francia- diario
libération now sea una portada realmente
impactante publicada tras difundirse el
vídeo de la brutal paliza que recibió
por parte de la policía un productor de
música negra que en parís por no llevar
mascarilla un episodio que ha generar
una gran polémica en francia- diario le
monde policia macrón ante una crisis
transformada en política de esa
vertiente política también vamos a
hablar hoy en el programa l'humanité
de filmar somos vulnerables son los
testimonios que recoge el rotativo de
varios manifestantes que han salido a
protestar en los últimos días contra esa
ley polémica en francia que quiere
restringir filmar a las fuerzas del
orden
bueno rafael parece que hay varios
elementos que nos han traído a este
punto pero como hemos llegado a esta
crisis
de confianza entre ciudadanos y policía
en francia el tema de la violencia
policial siempre ha sido un tema de
debate político en francia basta con
escuchar cualquier canción de hip hop de
los años 90 o hasta ahora para darse
cuenta de que es un tema pero claro
hasta ahora o hasta hace un par de años
pues se hablaba mucho de violencia
policial desde los suburbios desde esas
partes del territorio en los que hay más
crimen más delincuencia más presencia
policial
bueno lo que cambió a mi punto de vista
es que a partir del movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos mucha gente bueno que
no habían estado en manifestaciones en
protestas en su vida hasta este
movimiento pues de pronto estuvieron
frente a
la represión porque también algunas de
las protestas estaban muy violentas
entonces claro ese tema de la violencia
policial que hasta ahora pues se vivía y
se criticaba desde los suburbios ahora
pues se debate se critica desde sectores
mucho más anchos de la población a esto
hay que añadir pues en casos muy
mediáticos muertes claro en las que
estuvo involucrada la policía bueno esa
anciana de massey que murió a raíz de un
lanzamiento de granada accidental a
través de su ventana
suya que murió después de un control de
identidad que en parís y también estigma
ya kan ismo que murió en el río lugar en
donde después de la fiesta de la música
de este año entonces es un cóctel
bastante
terrible para la policía que explica que
ahora ese tema que bueno pues sí se
volvió un tema nacional discutido por
todos los sectores de la población desde
los suburbios hasta el campo los jóvenes
tanto los jóvenes como los más ancianos
miguel podemos decir que francia tiene
un grave problema con la violencia
policial a tenor de los últimos
episodios que hemos ido relatando de lo
que ha pasado sobre todo si yo creo que
me atravesé porque no sólo puedo decir
que la violencia policial en las
manifestaciones por lo menos en los
últimos dos años y por supuesto en las
últimas tres semanas a raíz de esta
presentación de la ley de seguridad
global la violencia publicidad
sistemática en las manifestaciones a
pesar de que podamos hablar de
provocadores o cosas por el estilo es
sistemática y esto ha traído una
represión y agregando lo que lo que
estaba diciendo federico creo que
también hay un punto muy importante que
hoy vemos esta violencia policial por la
manera en que nosotros periodistas todos
los mecanismos que tenemos para informar
y la gente que tiene para estar
informada que son redes sociales hoy
todo el mundo tiene una
tiene un teléfono el movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos marcó un antes y un
después en muchas cuestiones tanto el
periodismo porque ellos estaban todo el
tiempo en directo las páginas de los
chalecos amarillos estaban en facebook o
en twitter en directo y grababan toda
esta situación que se estaba viviendo al
inicio de la de la crisis de los
chalecos amarillos de los en los campos
elíseos que eran imágenes de
insurrección que pone como tales una
insurrección que se vive al inicio de la
crisis de los chalecos amarillos y que
pone de rodillas al al software fea
vamos a decir del mantenimiento del
orden de la policía francesa y que bueno
en toda su en todas sus filas tiene crea
un caos toda esta situación de no saber
cómo controlar esta situación y son dos
años que han pasado y lo seguimos
viviendo
esta situación caótica en los comandos
de la policía francesa yo creo que todos
recordamos aquellas imágenes de los
chalecos amarillos federico una parte de
la población observa con desconfianza
las sus fuerzas del orden tras episodios
de violencia contra manifestantes o con
los comportamientos racistas al mismo
tiempo los agentes se sienten
injustamente señalados víctimas de
campañas de odio y recuerdan las
agresiones que periódicamente sufren y
las cifras de suicidio en su profesión
quizás la pregunta es cómo se arregla
esta fractura esta crisis de confianza
será políticamente porque el problema no
es solo como la la policía concibe su
acción en la sociedad el problema es que
detrás algunas políticas gubernamentales
que ponen la policía hacia
contradicciones que aumentan en el
sentido desconfianza o sea es muy muy
sorprendente que macro no se haya dado
cuenta del problema de la violencia
policial y de las discriminaciones que
la policía hace a diario hacia personas
negras o musulmanas con ciertas orígenes
sociales tras un acontecimiento
totalmente excepcional como lo que hemos
vivido con michelle declare necesitamos
tres policías
increíblemente estúpidos como para no
darse cuenta que estén filmados para
entrar en un lugar pegado con una cámara
de vigilancia otra excepcionalidad para
darle una paliza a un ciudadano negro
con insulto racista y sin motivo
judicial para darnos cuenta como en la
muerte filmada de georges floyd que la
policía hace esto a diario
cotidianamente
y en nuestro ministro del interior sigue
diciendo que no hay violencias
policiales o sea que el término sigue
siendo controvertido esa es una falta de
reconocimiento para todos los ciudadanos
que siguen siendo discriminados en la
acción policial
de acuerdo con lo que han dicho los
otros intervinientes en el hecho que
esto empieza con los chalecos amarillos
ahí hay como algo que se rompe en la
confianza que la política de la
población tiene hacia la policía y hay
que acordar que en este en esta época en
diciembre de 2018 con el permiso de
nicole de la ministra de la justicia la
policía podía perseguir los
manifestantes por razones absurdas por
traer máscaras anti gas lacrimógeno por
echar agua sobre la policía o sea además
de quedarse con hándicap permanentes
muchos chalecos amarillos ha ido a la
cárcel por haber utilizado como armas
por destino objetos que nadie
consideraría como armas y en este
contexto es normal que haya habido
muchísima incomprensión entre la
población y la policía por cada chaleco
amarillo arbitrariamente encarcelados
haya vida ha habido docenas y docenas de
personas parientes familiares
los vecinos que se han disgustado por la
policía y esta represión policial no ha
cesado la hemos visto también con los
movimientos sociales del año 2019 y
hasta ahora con la ley de seguridad
global o sea esta doctrina y término de
represión que empieza históricamente los
años 70 de los eeuu que se llama
doctrina de represión preventiva o sea
para evitar violencias durante las
manifestaciones se reprime de manera
preventiva se detiene muy eficaz para
reprimir pero no es nada eficaz para
legitimar democráticamente la acción
policial que es el problema en lo que
nos encontramos hoy se refería a
federico también a esas imágenes de que
hayamos nombrado de esa brutal paliza un
productor de música negro por no llevar
mascarilla que pudo acá para acabar
perfectamente siendo un caso george
floyd a la francesa sucedió el pasado 21
de noviembre en rafael miguel el impacto
fue mayor porque creíamos que este tipo
de escenas eran más propias de un país
como eeuu que no de uno como francia
yo creo que en este caso la diferencia
es la grabación claro tenemos las
imágenes y las imágenes bueno a pesar de
lo que diga el sindicato los sindicatos
de policías pues el vídeo de ambiente y
es más el medio que difundió ese vídeo
difundió la integridad la integralidad
del vídeo sin cortes sin nada y aún así
hubo pues un par de sindicatos de
sindicatos policiales perdón que dijeron
que todavía esperaban a que un juez
dijera
cuál es la responsabilidad de los
policías entonces yo creo que es bueno
aparte de la de la brutalidad del
paciente de la de la paliza que nos dice
justificación alguna y también está el
tema de la mascarilla también bueno yo
no creo que haya ayudado en la defensa
de los policías pero eso es tenemos un
vídeo de 15 minutos y aún así pues
muchos policías se niegan a decirlo lo
que es la verdad de todo el mundo puede
entender que de que bueno esto no es
representativo de la policía en su
conjunto pero ahí tenemos yo creo que el
punto de ruptura es que aún con las
imágenes no avanzamos en el tema de que
hay un punto muy importante que cuando
se revelan estas imágenes
la agresión ya fue y michel se crea ya
está como está a punto de ser condenado
porque los policías habían declarado que
había intentado robarle sus armas y
estaba en una situación de rebelión
contra la autoridad quien hubiera
querido la versión hay una mentira por
parte de la policía porque aquí es
totalmente una mentira por parte de la
policía y yo no entiendo cómo los
sindicatos hoy siguen defendiendo esa
postura y no solamente las imágenes de
seguridad las que presenta este este
medio de comunicación también se basan
en lo que están grabando los vecinos
porque ahí creo que hay 23 imágenes de
teléfono de lo que pasa al interior con
la cámara de seguridad y después lo que
pasa al exterior cuando lo sacan después
de una granada lacrimógena al interior
de una casa entonces es una el uso
desproporcionado de la fuerza
nadie puede entender por qué se trabajó
a 15 20 policías para para esto también
yo creo que es otro elemento de la gente
no entiende con todos los temas de
seguridad que tenemos
que esto haya sido una importancia no
tiene sentido dar unos breves instantes
os vamos a ir a una breve pausa y a la
vuelta tenemos un montón de temas para
poner encima de la mesa entre ellos que
podemos esperar de esa reforma prometida
por emanuel macrón de esa reforma
policial para el mes de enero si la
volvemos
[Música]
ah
el director del centro de control y
prevención de enfermedades robert gray
field dijo que durante los próximos 60 a
90 días eeuu tendrá más muertes al día
que los registrados tras los ataques
terroristas del 11 de septiembre ataques
donde murieron 2 mil 977 personas cifra
récord que se da en medio de la
aprobación de la vacuna de fisión y su
distribución que según expertos empezará
a principios de la próxima semana ups se
encargará de la distribución de la
vacuna al este de estados unidos
mientras que fedex lo hará para el oeste
del país 6,4 millones de dosis serán
distribuidas en las primeras 24 horas de
distribución entretanto la cifra de
muertos en eeuu es cercana a las 300.000
y el número de contagios es de casi 16
millones de personas además hay una
crisis hospitalaria porque un tercio de
los centros médicos en eeuu ya no tiene
unidades de cuidados intensivos
disponibles para atender a los pacientes
[Música]
rusias del cuarto país del mundo con más
casos confirmados de kobe 19 aquí las
navidades duran 10 días o más
eso implica muchos desplazamientos para
ver a la familia más posibilidades de
contagio el gobierno ruso se ha
planteado incluso restringir la
movilidad entre regiones y en moscú se
han suspendido todas las actividades
navideñas prácticamente estos días se
aprecia un ligero descenso en el número
de contagios pero la capital rusa sigue
muy arriba en esa segunda ola estas
frías vacaciones rusas también suelen
conllevar un aumento del consumo de
alcohol un hábito que han desaconsejado
las autoridades sanitarias rusas a los
que se vayan a vacunar porque puede
obstaculizar la generación de
anticuerpos rusia ha inoculado ya a más
de 150.000 personas la vacuna contra la
cob in 19
[Música]
alemania registró este viernes un nuevo
récord nacional en el número de nuevos
casos de coronavirus en las últimas 24
horas también registró un nuevo récord
nacional en el número de nuevas muertes
por coronavirus en las últimas 24 horas
y esto se suma a que el 94% de los
distritos en el país actualmente son
considerados hotspots o zonas rojas todo
esto explica por que las medidas
impuestas por el gobierno tanto aquí en
berlín como en las diferentes regiones
del país para frenar el avance del
coronavirus simplemente no están dando
el resultado esperado es el octa un
parcial que está vigente desde
principios de noviembre y por el cual
los bares los restaurantes y los museos
debieron cerrar mientras que los
almacenes y los colegios permanecieron
abiertos de ahí que la pregunta en estos
momentos en alemán ya no es si las
autoridades van a tener que imponer
nuevas restricciones sino cuándo y qué
tipo de nuevas restricciones se habla
incluso de un lock down mucho más
completo similar al que vivió el país al
principio de la pandemia de tal manera
que los números de coronavirus puedan
reducirse
aquí en alemania
[Música]
sus historias inspiran el futuro su día
a día es la actualidad su cultura sus
luchas sus éxitos y están en el corazón
de nuestros programas les contamos los
que hicieron américa latina y los que la
construyen hoy les contamos un mundo
hecho día a día por los que lo habitan
liberté égalité actual y ti
seguimos en primera plana de radio
france internacional y de france 24 esta
semana hablando hablando de la crisis
policial aquí en francia con rafael plus
del diario la opinión miguel martínez
corresponsal de tv azteca y federico
tarragoní sociólogo especializado en
movimientos populares de la universidad
parís diderot hablamos de la crisis
policial que vive francia la semana
pasada en una entrevista en el medio
brut macrón pronunció la expresión
violencia policial y habló de sesgo
racial en controles callejeros
provocando un gran enfado entre
sindicatos policiales lo escuchamos y ha
relacionado con estos 7 y 107 wind o
fans de tafeta y tú no hay racismo en la
sociedad francés es un hecho y como
tenemos una policía imagen de la
sociedad hay miembros de la policía con
comportamientos y actitudes racistas que
no son aceptables y hay que perseguir y
sancionar
les pregunto miguel rafael les
sorprendió estas declaraciones de macrón
habrá que ver por qué tiene que haber
mucha pecado pedagogía detrás de lo que
para poder tener un
un regreso a la normalidad entre la
sociedad y la policía lo cual no ha sido
y no ha sido por parte del gobierno
francés y vuelvo a los movimientos
sociales de los últimos dos años
incluyendo los chalecos amarillos que el
gobierno la única hasta ahora la única
respuesta que ha tenido por ejemplo uno
de los ejemplos más claros ha sido la
creación por ejemplo de esta policía
motorizada que es la lava que se traduce
muy bien al espanyol que es la brigada
de represión y de acción violenta
motorizada es hacia la respuesta del
gobierno francés y de la policía que
muestra también lo que está diciendo
sobre el caos que se está viviendo en
los comandos de la policía entonces
habrá que haber mucha pedagogía entre la
sociedad lo que quiera la sociedad y con
la policía y también recordar que detrás
de todo esto hay muchos heridos durante
los movimientos sociales hay 32 personas
o más que han perdido el ojo durante las
protestas 5 mutilados estamos hablando
de que en francia o sea que ha sido el
uso de la fuerza desproporcionada la
semana pasada en republic el uso de
granadas de dispersión también dejó
nuevamente un
un mutilado que está en investigación
está hospitalizado y la investigación
sobre realmente lo que sucedió y por el
uso de este tipo de granadas que está
usando la policía entonces esta cuestión
de violencia de heridos que están
mutilados que han que han que han estado
a raíz de todas estas protestas
tiene que haber realmente una
una cuestión social para acercarse más a
la policía nos decía federico tarragona
y les sorprendió que el otro día macrón
emplear esos términos que hablara de
violencia policial y de sesgo racial en
control el señor tarragona
sí me sorprendió como lo como lo dije o
sea hace falta un acontecimiento
impensable en francia porque no estamos
en eeuu estamos en un país que no bueno
que no tiene el mismo tipo de
segregación racial de fracturas raciales
para que el presidente de la república
se dé cuenta que hay de hecho a diario
formas de discriminación racial en la
acción de la policía pero no me
sorprende muchísimo porque como lo decía
el periodista antes o sea es un
acontecimiento racista que le permite
decir esto pero macrón seguiría diciendo
que los manifestantes tienen que ser
reprimidos o sea que cuando uno hace una
manifestación que es una libertad
pública sagrada en francia es muy
importante es el país que ha hecho la
revolución en el 89 ya el país de mayo
68 ahora vivimos un momento de ruptura
con esta tradición histórica porque si
uno manifiesta puede perder un ojo
puede quedarse con andy acá pero puede
ir a la cárcel y esto macro nunca dirá
en la televisión que la policía reprime
las manifestaciones porque hay esta
doctrina de represión preventiva que
mete la policía hasta digamos delante el
hecho de reprimir antes que las
violencias pueda producirse para evitar
estas violencias y este es un fenómeno
que para mí es muy problemático porque
la gente sigue no entendiendo porque las
manifestaciones son reprimidas de esta
manera tan violenta por un presidente
que ha hecho toda su campaña electoral
con la palabra libertad osea macro no es
así se ha presentado como un candidato
muy liberal y con una concepción casi
izquierdista de la libertad o sea la
libertad de cultural de la libertad de
pública de libertad de expresión y se
está
de hecho manifestando como uno de los
presidentes más autoritarios de la
tradición democrática francesa contestó
de lo que estaba comentando federico
tarragoní habría que entender la
nominación de gerald a hermana en el
pasado verano como un ministro del
interior un hombre cercano al ex
presidente sarkozy que ahora está en
medio de toda la polémica partidario de
la mano dura en ciertos terrenos y que
ha levantado controversia desde que fue
nominado qué es lo que prendían macrón
con esta nominación de digamos esta
especie de poli duro al frente de
interior rafael primero quitarse de
encima existe externa que era el antiguo
ministro de interior y como lo acaba de
decir federico tenía un balance bastante
malo sobre el mantenimiento del orden
bueno también es verdad que nombrando a
la humana que es bueno viene de la
derecha conservadora que tiene posturas
bastante conservadoras respecto a la
seguridad y tal
se entiende como también una garantía de
seriedad porque claro el gobierno tanto
la izquierda como la derecha por ejemplo
los partidos llamados de gobierno no
quieren aparecer como anti policías
claro porque al fin y al cabo
si uno digo el presidente de la
república está bueno necesitamos de la
policía ese no es el temps y lo que pasa
es que el problema no es la postura
conservadora favorable a la policía que
esto bueno existe en todos los países y
es una corriente política respetable el
problema es el sentimiento de impunidad
el problema es esa impresión de quedar
mana siendo un conservador siendo en una
postura de apoyo acerca de lo de los
policías pues de la impresión de que
cuando los policías salen están fuera de
la legalidad pues el ministerio hasta el
último minuto hasta la última hora pues
va a intentar protegerles
la manada la impresión de que proteger
los policías es más importante que
simplemente la verdad de los hechos o el
respeto a las víctimas
la sanción pura y dura de
comportamientos que de todos modos no
están contemplados por los reglamentos
internos yo creo que ahí está la
diferencia entre la postura conservadora
clásica que todos conocemos y
el nutrir del sentimiento de impunidad
que a muchos franceses les parece
escandaloso vamos a ver las cosas
también desde el lado de la policía
porque lo cierto es que los últimos
cinco años para la policía han sido
duros aquí en francia en los años de
plomo del terrorismo yihadista
encadenados con protestas sociales casi
semanales no paraba antes mi compañero
mikel los chalecos amarillos en 2019 se
suicidaron 59 miembros de la policía
nacional según cifras policiales un 60%
más que el año anterior
federico esta dureza de los últimos
tiempos esta situación coyuntural
explica en parte esta crisis de
confianza la que hemos acabado llegando
entre policía y ciudadanos claro y creo
que estos problemas de sufrimiento que
vive la policía
tiene que ser explicado como también un
sentimiento de los ser reconocidos de
los policiales o sea que no se
reconozcan las especificidades de su
visión sus valores su sumisión cívica
también de protección de la de la
población es por eso que decía que es un
problema muy político o sea que desde
algunos años se ha impuesto a la policía
tareas que de que de hecho de
estabilizan la relación entre la policía
y los ciudadanos se le hace impuestos
por ejemplo de hacer peticiones de
ciudadanos musulmanos a las 5 de la
mañana en el marco de la ley de
antiterrorismo del estado de excepción
bajo el gobierno de françois hollande o
se le está imponiendo hoy de ir
recorriendo todo el territorio nacional
haciendo multas a los ciudadanos por
en los bosques puedo pasear por no
comprar cosas esenciales en los
supermercados por olvidar haber hecho
una autorización y eso aumenta por por
supuesto la desconfianza de la población
hacia la policía porque se percibe una
represión excesiva una presencia
excesiva de la policía en los espacios
públicos
y hasta privados de la gente y del otro
lado la policía tiene demasiados
funciones que no le incumbe porque la
única función que tendría que hacer la
policía es la función de protección del
orden público y se le dice repriman los
manifestantes controlen los ciudadanos
sean a cargo de toda la política
antiterrorista por supuesto eso crea
muchísimo estrés y la sensación un poco
como los enseñantes como los profesores
en en la educación secundaria que se les
dice sean asistentes sociales un poco
psicólogo un poco sociólogos y
enseñantes también
esto produce muchísimo estrés y por
supuesto también en casos de suicidios
de este tipo
está esta situación de la policía yo lo
vengo mencionando también es caótica
creo que lo vimos un ejemplo clarísimo
fue lo que sucedió hace tres semanas en
republica y no me equivoco cuando la
policía desaloja un campo de inmigrantes
y en realidad no son policías que están
especializados vamos a decir en el
mantenimiento del orden tienen que
llamar a una brigada que se encuentra en
los suburbios de país que está para
barrios sensibles porque no hay
suficiente personal en ese momento
cuando hay una protesta de los migrantes
que instalan sus tiendas de campaña y
traen a esta brigada y bueno la
respuesta policial ante esta
a esta manifestación en donde los
migrantes exigen no más estaban diciendo
estaban pidiendo en mejores condiciones
porque estamos en invierno estamos a 5
grados al exterior y llega la policía y
bueno vemos todas estas escenas de
violencia sacando a los migrantes
deficientes de campaña pero eso habla
también de un problema en el comando de
un problema en que hay falta de personal
eso es cierto y eso tiene que ver con
una reforma policial que como dijo
macrón vamos a ver qué es lo que
realmente podemos observar a obtener
francia y el gobierno con la policía
sino simplemente la gran paradoja es esa
crece la desconfianza hacia la policía
pero necesitamos más policías todos los
alcaldes los políticos locales dice la
delincuencia es real y es un problema
para la gente de verdad entonces
necesitamos más policías pero claro
más formados
esa es la paradoja yo creo que crece la
desconfianza pero al mismo tiempo todo
el mundo entiende de qué
necesitamos simplemente más presencia
policial en la vida cotidiana eso es de
todas maneras es lo que es lo que piden
los alcaldes por ejemplo es la paradoja
la paradoja a la que se enfrenta el
manuel macro para reformar la policía
como él mismo ha prometido a partir del
próximo mes de enero ante esta crisis
policial que vive francia muchísimas
gracias a los 3 federico tarragoní
miguel martínez rafael plus por haberme
acompañado en esta edición de primera
plana de todos ustedes les esperamos
aquí la próxima semana muchas gracias
[Música]